can you tell us what you is on your
heart that you want to share
i've ran for myself for a long time i've
hated myself for a long time and
i'm gay colton underwood is living in
his truth
for the first time nothing can prepare
you for this in a pre-taped interview
with robin roberts which
aired wednesday on good morning america
the former bachelor star reveals
publicly for the first time that he is
gay
i came to terms with that earlier this
year and have been processing it
and um the next step in all of this was
sort of
letting people know still nervous but um
yeah it's it's been a journey for sure
the 29 year old says that life in
quarantine over the past year
led him to do some soul searching and to
feel comfortable
opening up about his sexuality and he
says that his past struggle with his
identity
led him to quote suicidal thoughts i
would have rather died than say i i'm
gay
and i think that was sort of my wake-up
call there was a moment in l.a that i
woke up
and i didn't think i was going to wake
up
um i didn't have the intentions of
waking up and i did
and i think for me that was like my my
wake-up call
of like this is your life
take back control colton adds that he no
longer feels that way and that
opening up about being gay has led him
to a much better place in his life
i'm emotional but i'm emotional in like
such a good happy positive way
um like the happiest and healthiest i've
ever been in my life
and that means the world to me
as for appearing on the bachelor the
former reality star has
mixed feelings about his part in the
franchise
colton first competed on the 14th season
of the bachelorette starring becca
kufrin
before being announced as the season 23
bachelor
any hesitation on your part about being
asked to be the bachelor there probably
would have been a little hesitation if i
didn't do bachelorette or bachelor in
paradise
before because if i finally allowed me
to take a step back from those
situations see what i learned how i've
grown since i've been in that
and go from there so there was zero
hesitations you know sort of once it was
offered
the former football player's sexuality
first came up after he publicly revealed
his virginity while dating becca
i am a virgin really
at the time he remembered seeing
headlines saying he was gay
closeted or quote doing this for
attention
i do think i could have handled it
better i'll say that how so
i just i just wish i wouldn't have
dragged people into my own mess of
figuring out who i was
i i genuinely mean that
but i also at the same time like but i
can sit here and say i'm sorry to all of
those women i can also say thank you
because without them and without the
bachelor franchise
i don't know if i like this would have
ever came out and he recalls
this moment after finding out he was the
bachelor
i literally remember praying praying to
god
the morning i found out that i was a
bachelor and thanking him for making me
straight
i remember that vividly of saying like
finally you're letting me be straight
and while his bachelor season
didn't end with an engagement he did end
up in a relationship with winner cassie
randolph
the two dated for a year and a half
before their tumultuous breakup last may
i loved everything about her i'm sorry
for any pain
and emotional
stress i caused colton also revealed
that he has not had a romantic
connection with a man yet
i've never allowed myself to and it's
never been
sort of in my cards to let myself get
there and i want to more than anything
and
i'm looking for someone who can push me
and challenge me in all the great ways
since his interview aired colton has
received a ton
of love and support online in a
statement to e.t
the executive producers of the bachelor
said that they are quote
inspired by colton underwood's courage
to embrace and pursue his authentic self
bachelor host chris harrison broke his
social media silence amid his racism
scandal
to share this photo with colton and
assure he's got his full love and
support
anika and nicole former contestants on
colton's season
took to twitter anika writing that she
is happy for him
nicole writing that she is proud of him
andy cohen tweeted that colton is quote
free now lonnie love wrote life gets
better standing in your truth
while megan mccain sent quote love light
support and deep respect colton's way
you